did you think that your anxiety
and maybe depression really smallville
was the reason for that because there
was so much pressure and so much stress
and anxiety
to come on that show that that kind of
pushed it into a different direction
from that
do you blame small people for your
anxiety or did you like honestly because
like i remember i worked i worked i
worked i stressed i stressed i stressed
and then something was the
the tipping point something what that
got me over the edge where i'm like okay
now i have
uh anxiety that i can't really control
as easy as i used to be able to
i'm older now this has happened i've
gotta take a step back
and was it smallville or was it
something or did you always deal with it
it's always been part of my personality
but i didn't recognize it
for what it was and so it wasn't small
actually i got a lot from small it
pushed me out of out of
um myself right um
and i learned to trust myself a little
bit more and then as i went into saving
hope i really was thrown into the deep
water
myself um and and then you really start
to kind of keep your own counsel and go
it's good enough and you kind of move on
right i never really believed that
there's something like that that would
happen to me that i would actually get
to do the acting thing for real
right i was fully ready to kind of
continue on as everybody else i knew
went on and completely fine with it
right so when it came about it just
surprised me
and then took me a while to get my feet
under me but i loved it so much
um i think my anxiety and depression
came out after my second kid
and it was that's where it kind of got
triggered is that postpartum
yeah and i've never well i'm i'm
managing it much better but the
it really i don't know body chemistry of
what it was but when i
when i went to have lachlan my
five-year-old
we had to do lots of ivf we did quite a
few years of that
and so when you do that you really play
with your hormones a lot
and that can kind of affect all sorts of
things that can affect how you look how
you feel
but it can be forever like then your
your hormones are out of whack for a
really long time
and some of them don't really go back
right so if you think about all that
stuff that you're pumping through you
the only thing that i can kind of liken
it to and i don't know if you've ever
done this in your life and you don't
have to say
but when i try to explain it to a man i
say
have you ever done taken extra
testosterone to work out or have you
ever done a little bit of caffeine or
have you ever
and it gets that kind of rager and the
rager comes out
that's kind of like some of the the
hormones that i did only it lasted for
like
10 15 months right jesus so
i now when i look back on like how busy
it was how tired i was i was
i had two pregnancies while i was
working um
i was trying ivf for 10 years like so i
think it all just kind of
went to the point and then i had my
second son and then
saving hope was done then and it was
just like everything stopped right i've
been working for 15
16 years and and then it stopped and i
had nothing else to do
and then i have all these hormones and
these emotions right and i think that it
just kind of